from the city hardest hit by covid19
a warning the world is facing an even
bigger crisis
with the threat of climate change and
from new york
the u.n secretary general has made a
dramatic plea
to the global community to put it simply
the state of the planet is broken
dear friends humanity is waging war on
nature this is suicidal
nature always strikes back and it is
already doing so
with growing force and fury the un's
annual climate report read like a list
of natural disasters
record hurricanes in the atlantic and
central america
record wildfires and record temperatures
california alone saw the biggest fires
in its history this summer
and the hottest air temperature on the
planet in a century
if not ever and this year has seen
higher temperatures the world over
on land sea and especially the arctic
the average global temperature this year
is predicted to be around 1.2 degrees
celsius higher
than pre-industrial levels making the
last decade the warmest on record
with all six of the warmest years
occurring
since 2015 and with temperatures
expected to keep rising
the wmo warns without drastic action
the planet could warm by one and a half
degrees by 2024
jeffrey sachs who's advised three u.n
secretary generals
warned the world is facing a moment of
reckoning
we're human beings so sometimes we walk
right into disaster sometimes when we're
in disaster we don't behave well
so there's no guarantee that anything's
going to change
except for the fact that we've just gone
through the warmest ten years
in recorded history we're setting
records all the time
the disasters are all around us the un
has made clear climate change is now at
the heart
of its global mission as the world went
into various states of lockdown
greenhouse gas emissions were
temporarily reduced this year
but carbon dioxide levels in the
atmosphere are on the rise
and the un is warning without action the
world faces disaster
donald trump pulled america out of the
paris climate accord
and president-elect joe biden has
signaled he will reverse that move
on the day he enters office
john kerry has already been appointed as
the biden administration's climate envoy
the former secretary of state already
pledging
failure is not an option wildfires have
once again returned to australia
along with record-breaking temperatures
the apocalyptic scenes of last year
still raw while there is no vaccine to
fix the planet
2020 has proven human beings are capable
of drastic action in the face of a
crisis
sally lockwood sky news new york